with platonic dialogues how can that be
done well you you try to get the
students to see themselves in the
dialogues
are you this kind of person are you this
kind of person you know agreeing with
socrates at this point means you have
something in common with this guy who
died two millennia ago
that means something
recognizing the attitudes of others
you know recognizing
why people do bad things
those dialogues are about right and
wrong
and the motivations for
doing things
well or doing them or
treating people well or treating them
poorly
caring by this think means what we would
call affectivity
um and what we want to do ultimately is
get our students not just to acquire
skills but to to want to practice those
skills
so with platonic dialogues
ultimately we can move hopefully
students away from passive to active and
engaged attitudes and to be active and
engaged itself is not simply
dispositional it's effective
it's because the students want
things they desire
to learn also becoming interested in
understanding the subjects of the
dialogues
platonic dialogues were designed to be
read and re-read and thought about for
years the
guy who i studied
plato symposium with for an entire
semester in greek
rick williams from southern illinois
university
he'd been studying it for for 40 years
he'd been reading and rereading the
symposium and i asked him about that and
he said well
i won't say that every single time i
read it i find something new because
after 40 years you should have most of
it down
but there are still unanswered questions
for me that keep me coming back to the
dialogue they're that sort of product
and so i think if we can get our
students to desire
understanding the things in those those
dialogues or in other
you know great philosophical texts or
other great pieces of literature
things that we want to expose our
students to
and we would love to see them
loving
that's what we want for them right we
want them to become interested in really
grasping these things
then finally learning how to learn
plato's dialogues themselves are about
education
what are the obstacles to becoming
engineering
what are the things that help
for our students
just learning how to learn dimension
means learning
what lower order skills they need to
work on so i think we have to identify
those in the assignment sheets that we
give them to say this is actually what
we're doing here this is not the whole
of you know understanding plato but this
is going to be a building block
and then learning how to progressively
move
that might take
putting together maps
for our students
i do this with some
other assignments that use
lower order skills and then to higher
order skills i think our students
probably
these days actually need
physical maps that they can they can see
and say oh i get why i'm doing this now
because
i don't think we can take for granted
that they they have any understanding of
these things at least the students that
need you
so
um
like i put on here
you can find
fuller treatment of this on my faculty
website
this is a long url but you can just go
to uncfsu's website type in sadler and
my website will come up
any any questions about this
no perfectly clear all right
i think it's
it's very interesting in terms of
moving from those lord
thinking i think
yeah and i think it tells us that uh
whenever we understand concepts
we can move further but unless the
fundamentals are there if students are
not learning fundamentals it's very
difficult for them to solve the move
into the higher order
way of learning and sometimes we are so
concerned about coverage yeah we do not
spend enough time
um
knowledge base
to ensure that students i know i and i
have done that over and over again that
privileging
covering the what i think has to be
done in the class or
hitting those lower order skills and
really spending a lot of time and
practicing
the other obstacle i found on my part
was i didn't even have any idea what
level of skills
because for me
it was just sort of automatic well you
get the dialogue you just read it and
you know you know who's talking at what
point and what they're done with the
smaller arguments are oh that's
perfectly clear
but for my students they you know it
took me a while to realize
that they they simply didn't grasp those
i think we don't do enough of that in
school in the classroom
we don't
we don't and you know
uh
i think most teachers think that's just
a waste of time to give them the support
that they really need by asking certain
questions yeah you know and
they come in with the preconceived idea
that uh notion that students know how to
do this
thinking
and when they really they have no idea
and that's what really you know
uh
get them frustrated as you alluded to
the students frustrated and the teacher
also right and then at least
you know it's kind of joking to put into
that missile map that you know playing
off of the this answer to things about
the taste it's great for students
there is a real danger and i see this in
a lot of my peers you know i'm on
facebook with a lot of my
fellow philosophers and they you know
complain about their students and they
assign this the students didn't
it's kind of dangerous for classroom
teaching because students perceive that
if you come in
and your attitude as well most of you
are dummies you're not going to get this
i'm just teaching to those three
students who are
worthy of
being taught
you know that destroys the classroom
situation from the start
especially you know it's worse when it's
our fault
and we philosophers are probably the
worst
the teachers say you know read the
chapter explained and they just can't
concept conceptualize what's going on
and then i think
the
professor doesn't realize that you have
different learning styles different ways
to reach other students and it's just
open the book start talking and then
okay see you next week do the chapter
reading and they get frustrated
especially with philosophy
and logics you know
part of the
reason is because philosophy deals with
some of the most general
concepts
it has a long history because it was a
large canon
and it's got this emphasis on putting
together arguments
and so that's all you know pretty high
order stuff
and we we put it in a 100 level class we
require a whole bunch of students to
take it and then we put in uh professors
who
haven't thought much about that and you
know thought that that was just well
that's philosophy of education i don't
have to fool around with that
and i i actually think that
you know i go around and i talk to
people there's a broader topic but i
talk to people and say what do you do
for a living while i teach philosophy oh
i took that class was awful
and i hear that over and over and over
again i think there must be
a lot of very bad philosophy professors
out there in the last several
generations
and we're just you know we're turning
people off and the problem is
the products that we have to offer you
know like plato's dialogues
um
they're wonderful they have all these
dimensions to them
when people actually do get into them
they love them they want to keep
studying them
and somehow we just keep
closing doors instead of opening for our
students
that's a bigger picture
perhaps
but let's face it a lot of people who
teach philosophy who become philosophers
are very bright people
who go straight on they've never been in
a classroom they don't they have never
learned how to teach yeah and so they
don't think about
how students learn
you just have this wonderful thing and
we must all just absorb it
but then
my second experience was very good it
was at tuskegee university and we had
this dr handy who was a wonderful
teacher and then i was like oh this is
philosophy isn't this wonderful yeah no
then i could see that it really was
it taught me thinking processes yes
as well so i mean you know but if we
could just
get our philosophy teachers to
understand or to take a course in
teaching methodology then take a search
yes and take it seriously
but that's true in general isn't it it's
it's it's it's true in general because
a part of my responsibility at faithful
state university is to teach teachers
how to teach and one of the things that
i say to my teacher education students
is the vast majority of their professors
are content experts who don't have a
flying clue as to how to convey that
content
because what what what at
higher education what we tend to do is
to hire experts in their areas
really to to to to teach
but these are not expert teachers and so
that's where the big divide is that and
i i think that's the big big divide in
higher education and so for
particularly for college professors who
don't get that they think why isn't this
student like me when i was a student
forgetting how they were when they were
a student
see and and and so i know fayetteville
state university is really doing
something about it now and a lot of
institutions are really doing something
about trying to understand and put put
put um grasp this this concept of
no the teacher has to be taught how to
teach in order to be a teacher
and i often say
we do not take that approach with
airplane pilots
there's no such thing as a as
as a born pilot
people are trained to be pilots just as
we are trained
to be
teachers
we're trained to be teachers just to put
it in certain statistical perspectives
in philosophy our flagship
organization is the american
philosophical association and if you go
to the eastern
division which is the main one you'll
see anywhere from 1500 to 2000 people
the american association of philosophy
teachers which really focuses on
scholarship of teaching and learning and
you know has workshops
on how to teach philosophy well
there
are a good conference attendance is 120
so that gives you an idea about
even today in 2010
what the proportion is of
those who are just you know content
experts and
want to do their their thing and those
who are actually
trying to to use the research that's
available or further the research that's
available and
teach well
and i suspect that it's probably
somewhere in some of the other
communities as well history
for
they don't ask english right questions
the philosophers don't know no they
don't let me tell you why i say that
because
they would ask students what do you
think yeah and when the uh students give
them their opinions how they are
thinking that's oh no that's true
yeah that's right
so then they don't answer they turn it
off you know making the students feel as
though they can think they can't learn
but again they're not trained
to ask the students
the correct question
and so both the teacher and the student
are now frustrated yeah because they're
both lost i mean literally it's a
situation where the blind is leading the
blind i'm told both will fall into the
ditch
and isn't that what we're seeing in many
instances because both have fallen into
the ditch when we do our statistical
analyses of that
it's very clear to us
what's going wrong here well both are
falling into the ditch
and you know the really sad thing about
it is
within each great philosophical
tradition not just in western philosophy
but also eastern philosophy
those who
are part of the canon they were all
great teachers
think about plato aristotle's socrates
you know the reason why we read
epictetus the stomach is because
somebody wrote his discourses down
because he was such a great teacher in
the east you know think about the role
of confucius
um
and yet the people who teach about these
often don't even you know read aristotle
talks about teaching
over and over and over again but a lot
of the aristotle scholars just skip over
those passages
so
that's